can you explain Waianae
to people who have never been to Hawaii
even people who have been to like
Honolulu and stuff oh yeah because I
think it's a very specific
part
of Hawaii in that I think it's like the
only part that's not gentrified at all
yeah yeah it's super awesome it's
getting scary though wait what you mean
I mean it's getting broad the whites are
coming bro The Hollies are coming bro
are we scooping it up I know you your
people
with that haircut
but yeah bro I mean I mean to explain
why not you're not gonna like it but the
coffee gets better the dessert gets
better the coffee in Hawaii
okay okay so tell me if I if I had to
explain why I would be like it would be
a place where a person would literally
give you the back of their uh the shirt
off their back or you come there you
just get beaten off there's only two
things
you want to get a shirt you know it's
it's a how you you know that side of the
island it's like a lot of people look at
you like damn yes and I mean and like
people take it wrong because that's that
Island It's Always Sunny is this the sun
in our eyes
it's the sun in our eyes it's not it's
not you guys so just be nice if you be
nice people can be nice they're gonna
welcome you but if you if you give a
little attitude it's on it brother I was
I was telling my guy but over here he's
talking to me uh off camera about some
some situation I thought bro if I was
with you I would have told him I would
have told that guy back the hell up man
I don't give a [__] who you are
you know so are you are you still like
in situations where you Gotta Throw Down
even now no nobody's testing you right
now everybody's cool bro I'd be nice
that's why you'd be nice to everybody
yeah it comes back and nah nah they all
love it you know I'm like you can you
can walk around there without getting
harassed you know I mean it's like uh
the best way to explain it is like it's
like LeBron in Ohio you know like when
people when you go down there and
everybody's like that's [__] LeBron
like they they see him all the time in
Acron you know they see me every time I
said I am
born and raised out there so at the end
of the day it's just okay it's another
day that's that's the wildest thing for
me because most people
reach your super stardom and they will
move right especially in MMA a lot of
people will go to one of the big MMA
gyms yeah in America where it was
America top team yeah uh there's a few
of them what is the one in Denver uh
that uh I think it's Usman training out
of there gay cheese training out of
there I don't know what it is
I'm terrible bro I'm so far apart if you
ask me about video games
every streamer every step you didn't
move and I thought it was an interesting
thing like hey not only did you not move
you didn't even move to a bougie area uh
I still live in Waianae and I actually
and actually me and my me and my wife
right now is we're going to we actually
just got land we actually moved deeper
into Waianae towards Macau where she's
from so like we're out there at the end
and see how they do they bring you over
there just slowly drag you out bro he's
gentrifying Iolani bro
[Laughter]
Obama's one
so would you guys would you like go [__]
them up like would you and your boys go
[__] them up no I wouldn't I don't do
nothing bro I wasn't a fighter in school
but then when we when they did when uh
when guys would fight they would it
wasn't those ones it was the other
problem excuse bro yeah yeah none of
these uh
I think so these these rich guys was
like pretty smart to stay away from work
like pretty smart I mean the guys are
smart the girls would actually mess with
some of the ones
Romeo and Juliet
the good dick on that side of the island
long dig wine that's what I call it
okay so no fighting man that's weird so
how do you even find out you're good at
fighting yeah brother I just I mean
Pokemon cards
you found out that this [__]
trade you for this two cards thinking it
was great if I have like three cars but
he took your shine he's like whoa you
screwed me
and that's my best friend though but I
fought one time in the eighth grade and
I would have to say I won the fight only
because I landed the only punch in the
fight you know what I mean like uh my
younger my younger brother was a fighter
so like you know long story short if uh
when I started kickboxing whatever my
cousin uh my mom then would like tell my
aunt to them oh you coming to Max's
fight you're coming to Max's fight and
my younger brother's name is Clinton
there's like you mean clam they're like
no no no no they thought they thought my
younger brother was a fighter so I I
ended up become the fighter I have I
have no idea why maybe I was smarter my
younger brother was just bronze I guess
and I guess I was the brain so bro
there's a thing in in Hawaii that's so
interesting it's like the kindest
sweetest most welcoming people that also
will fight bro yeah can you explain how
that comes together because
I've never met a Hawaiian that I thought
was [__] but never once every one of
them is like the sweetest kindest guy
who's like oh yeah my shoulder's [__]
up and like why is I just had to murder
this guy
how does that happen how are you the
nicest people and also fighting is like
part of the culture is this is what she
says the culture bro I think so back in
the day uh you know with a Hawaiian
culture was a lot of it was hand-to-hand
contacts we didn't really have weapons
until somebody came and colonized me
we brought
[Laughter]
the map down there is this in our blood
it's in our blood you know we have our
we have our own fighting style it's
called the Lua you know what I mean and
then like like yeah like a martial arts
yeah Hawaiian martial arts so it's
pretty sick there's a book and stuff but
it's like it's very like it's very
grungy bro like grabbing sand you know
grabbing testicles and twisting and
pulling oh it's it's a gangster it's
funny big Tongan girl user as a shield
or something
you know it was funny because like I
like uh my older brother is in into uh
into the Hawaii culture and everything
and I remember telling one time like oh
yeah you know uh like uh in my ex at the
time I was like I just leave her home
you know why he's coming to fight you
don't bring you don't bring uh you you
don't bring your wife to to a fight and
then but Hawaiian Warriors they used to
bring yeah the girls used to be Warriors
too so also they were scrapping it's
crap too to fight front lines so it's
kind of like Avengers yeah
when I figured out I was like that's
pretty crazy damn bro WWE bro that's
dope
I take over yeah where are all the
female
fighters from Hawaii bro I have no idea
bro I have no idea they're working at
Walmart or whatever remember that girl
was serious that was impressive she lost
her job because how crazy is that yeah
she lost her job a female football
league that'll probably hire her you
know I mean being a white Hider I think
danaway higher as a security guard for a
little while yeah I don't know if he's
if she still is but he did she got fired
from Walmart Oh Best Buy was Best Buy
yeah because you can't do that I'm like
can't do what stop someone even stealing
yeah they're the worst things that could
happen than getting fired from Walmart
though I'll tell you that right now I
think she can be okay did you ever have
fights in baseball like there'd be like
a baseball like all the benches clear
and then you just go with brawl no I
never did I never did